tami Cup Georgia Cooper Hara Sheldon
Cooper absent where's your brother huh
is he okay yeah he's just actually it's
not looking good for him he might not
make it
that's terrible you know I love him so
much
if anything ever happened I don't know
what I'd do
she only if you don't mind me asking
what's your long-term plan here I'm
working on the math to turn the garage
into a self-sustaining ecosystem okay
and what exactly does that mean
well all I need is sunlight and a few
seeds to grow unlimited food which I'll
fertilize with my own feces this just
gets better if you're not gonna help
please go inside this is not a show now
that's where I disagree
Shelly baby please come on out I can't
come on I'm your mommy
do it for your mommy no but I'm your
mommy I think the Sun is part about it
it's just how sad it is is there
anything that we can do I don't know a
hug might help of course what's wrong
with you two
don't you care about my brother
[Music]
that's it I've had enough of this
nonsense if you don't come out I'm
coming in 1 2 3
preach preach you come here right this
instant no I don't have to do forever
just till you get tired
Sheldon Lee Cooper
[Music]